[Music]
some YouTube creators are upset that
YouTube is automatically D monetizing
certain video game videos with its
machine learning algorithm the suggested
explanation is the depiction of guns
though YouTube denies this gamers who
previously made money on the platform
now find their revenue drying up in the
big picture the issue is about how to
fund content and its delivery now gamers
or game companies could make their own
platform and charge a fee for users to
participate but many prefer advertising
funded content rather than paying out of
pocket the trouble is that advertising
dollars are increasingly concentrated
with a few ad platforms unfortunately
this trend has been strengthened in part
by the FCC's title to net neutrality
rules which block game makers and gamers
from finding alternative models for
advertising particularly from their ISP
in the meantime we should welcome the
emergence of alternative platforms
patreon and twitch but we also need more
diversity in the business models to
bring competition to the concentrated ad
platform market removing the FCC's net
neutrality rules is a step in the right
direction to learn more about my take on
tech policy check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI